so this is the room that we're able to
offer
double bed and a single bed on the floor
hannah and matt want their spare room to
become a sanctuary but ensuite bathroom
so we're thinking that a couple or a
couple and a child they plan to offer it
up for free to a family who have fled
the war in ukraine
it's a moral obligation i think for us
all here to be able to do something
we've got the space to do this
yeah we've got a family we've got
children but
why would we refuse these people that
are in desperate need they're planning
to sign up for the government's new
homes for ukraine scheme which will
allow people to sponsor refugees to come
and stay with them even those with no
family ties to the uk
the government says people offering a
room or a whole property rent free will
get 350 pounds a month as a thank you
those with accommodation will be vetted
and ukrainian applicants will be
security checked and the offer must be
for a minimum of six months it's quite a
big commitment isn't it six months
minimum it is but then
six months kind of isn't a long time
either and
we would welcome people to our home for
longer than that because we recognize
the plight that they've come from the
government has been criticized for its
response to the ukrainian refugee crisis
but charities say they hope this new
scheme will help thousands more in just
a week we've seen seven and a half
thousand people say that they want to
open their homes to welcome refugees
it's still an uncapped program that
means if we can find a sponsor a family
can come so if
20 000 sponsors come forward then that's
20 000 families that's huge
a website for the scheme is due to
launch tomorrow so people like hannah
and matt can offer a safe place for
those who have left everything behind
katie barnfield sky news